你像他和他爸妈之间的关系，
是他们之间的缘分和因果，
你不能强求你的老公去问他爸妈要钱，
你不能撺掇你老公去问他爸妈要钱，
你不能以己度人，
你觉得没关系，
你就让你老公去干这个事儿，
那不就日子就过不下去了吗？
那之天的话是今年36天，
然后我老公是结婚两年，
然后他是比我大八岁，
就是40年多嘛，
我们俩都是在私企工作，
他是有一个早婚未育的一个经历，
我是第一次结婚，
私企工作的话收入还是可以的，
这情况的话，
就他的家庭就是比较好一点，
是大富大贵吧，
但是父母年轻的时候也是积累了一定的就是财富吧，
我这边的话就是普通家庭，
其实我俩在相处上来说没有什么问题，
就是他对我也比较包容，
我俩就感觉一直是有一个结，
但父母一直对他要求比较严格，
就属于打架式教育啊，
他现在他父母这块儿很害怕他父母对他的一些支持和帮助，
他父母一旦伸手要父母的东西，
他就会觉得他父母就是会瞧不起他，
或者是什么样的，
就算其实我相处下来，
我公公婆婆不是这样的，
就是他们现在也支持了嘛，
还是希望我们俩能好，
因为我们俩现在也是怀孕了，
但是她40多岁，
这个年龄就是只有一个宝宝，
大家就是支持我，
包括从怀孕前到现在金钱上的支持，
很痛快，
不是那种吝啬的那种，
恰长但是。
就我老公就是每次他父母给钱的时候就是很别扭，
好像不愿意接受那样子，
好像我就是有点必要他父母钱的那个意思，
这事儿一个过程，
现在是有一个比较大的一个问题，
就是想换一个车，
就是把旧个车置换以后再添一个钱，
其实对于换车我是没有太多想法，
他觉得毕竟有孩子了，
把他带一点换的话，
可能还差个十几万，
他的意思就是说你拿我俩的一些积蓄，
因为之前他父母也给过钱，
包括他的工资也会上交一部润给我了，
用这些钱去换这个车，
但我就觉得其实我俩虽然收入还可以啊，
但是也花钱比较大手大脚，
没有什么太太多钱，
如果说拿全部的这个目前结婚的积蓄去换这个车，
我是不愿意的，
但是我老公就会觉得好像之前说过这个事儿，
我说我只能出这小几万，
剩下的我的意思就是说可以跟他父母去说这个事情，
那他就是说不行，
而且他还说就是这钱啊，
进你口袋就掏不出来的意思，
他也不想跟他父母说这个事情，
包括他跟他父母这个关系的，
就一直就很别扭，
我不知道要怎么相处，
其实他他对钱，
他对我也是挺大方的，
他只是不愿意接受父母的钱，
因为我现在怀孕了，
后期的话可能面临着是到40岁，
工作上确实比较再难找了，
就是父母要需要帮衬的地方肯定会越来越多，
用钱的地方越来越多，
如果他总是这别别扭扭的，
我就不知道应该怎办，
我觉得这事儿啊，
第一确实量力而行。
就是假设你们现在的存款是三十万四十万，
没有必要说这三十万四十万都拿来换一个车，
他觉得反正就是还会再有钱的，
因为我俩其实没有任何房贷压力，
车贷压力，
然后包括父母那边其实是有资边可以支持我俩，
包括我俩工作也还可以，
他就想就是都花，
这个事情是这样的，
因为孩子还没有出生，
孩子在从你肚子里到出生这一路走过来，
到底要花多少钱的话，
他是个未知数，
我在这里没有别的意思啊，
不是说呃，
每个人都会遇到，
说孩子有什么问题呀，
孕妇有什么高血压呀，
有什么糖尿啊，
有什么这有什么那有什么产前需要保胎啊，
不是说每个人都会遇到，
但这个钱得预味着就这如果说真的对孩子负责任的话，
你最起码得预备个8万十万的钱，
就在孩子出生这个过程当中的，
包括孩子生完了之后，
育儿嫂你干一个月了之后，
你未必能上手，
有月嫂有可能要干3个月，
甚至有可能要干4个月，
你才能上手，
这些钱都得预备出来，
我觉得你应该从这个角度去聊一下，
说买车这个事情的话，
要么就缓一缓，
因为小孩子从出生到他真正需要用车，
还有很长的一个阶段，
对现在的问题就是我其实对于换车这个没有什么太大的想法，
就可换可不换，
但是先不换，
没有他现在感，
没有那个劲儿，
他就是想换，
因为他知道我俩就是他妈也给了我们一些钱嘛，
包括他也工资给了我一些他。
对对对，
你又不是换不起那个车，
他们之前说过就在你口袋好像就掏不出来，
还是这个意思，
我觉得这个沟通的问题也可以折中一下，
就是说你老公交给你的工资，
你说老公我也要尊重你，
你交给我的工资我可以给你，
在这个基础之上，
你去想要换一辆什么样的车，
但是你现在想要说我把所有的钱都给你的话，
我认为我要对我的生命和我孩子的生命负责任，
因为我是36岁了，
也算是高龄产妇了，
在怀孕生孩子这个过程当中，
难免会出现一些不可控的风险，
那我的钱又用来保我的命和我的孩子的命，
和咱们孩子的命折重一下方案，
那在和她父母的这个沟通是，
至于父母这个事情的话，
我有一个可能大家不太支持的方案，
这个方案就是你老公的事儿，
尊重你老公，
他不愿意问他父母要钱，
你就别撺掇他问他父母要钱，
但是你可以不穷吗？
不要留下任何证据嘛，
你可以跟公公婆婆在一起的时候，
又说钱不太够用嘛，
公公婆婆愿意给你钱，
这是公公婆婆给你的，
跟他有什么关系？
尤其是将来有了孙子了，
有了小孩儿了，
我老公不愿意问他妈要钱，
我就别撺掇他问爸妈要钱，
但是爷爷奶奶给孙子的钱，
我可以大大方方接着嘛，
这不就日子就好过了吗？
其实在这次换车就告诉他父母，
他其实就是怕他父母会支持他，
都会给他一点钱，
他说哪怕就是。
我俩贷款就是后期慢慢还也行，
但我就觉得这个也没什么不可说的吧，
就是爷爷奶奶我觉得支持一下也没有什么。
我跟你讲了，
人家他和他爸妈之间的关系，
是他们之间的缘分和因果，
你不能强求你的老公去问他爸妈要钱，
你不能撺掇你老公去问他爸妈要钱，
你不能以己度人，
你觉得没关系，
你就让你老公去干这个事儿，
那不就日子就过不下去了吗？
你得尊重他。
至于说将来你的公公婆婆和你的关系，
和你生的孩子之间的关系，
这又是两条不同的线，
两条不同的社会关系，
不要强求你老公去问他爸妈要钱，
明白我可能在沟通上我不知道怎么跟他父母说，
让他我是在告状，
就像你说的哭求或者是怎么着了，
但我觉得你这个情况就是先在生孩子之前这个阶段，
先别指着爷爷奶奶给钱这个事儿了，
先生孩子这个阶段，
先就着我有多少钱，
我要留多少钱在我的手里，
保证我能顺利的生孩子，
先把这个态度摆明，
其实我手里是有这么多钱，
但是我就强硬一点，
跟我老公不说了，
我不可能都给你，
我别强硬的说，
沟通它是需要技巧，
这个沟通的技巧是什么呢？
哎呀，
老公，
我昨天做了一个梦啊，
梦到我在怀孕生孩子这个过程当中啊，
出现了什么情况，
要花好多钱。
什么的，
我觉得这可能是一种预兆，
所以呢，
就是买车这个事情呢，
它毕竟不涉及到命，
不涉及到健康，
不涉及到我和孩子的生命问题，
所以在这件事情上的话，
还是要优先保证我和孩子的生命安全，
健康排在第一位，
所以呢，
我能给你一部分钱，
比如说你今年交工资给我交了8万块钱，
我给你这8万块钱，
然后你来做决定。
沟通这个事情得有技巧，
有的时候示弱，
有的时候掉眼泪，
有的时候甚至各种玄学你都用上，
你及做梦嘛，
又这又那了的话，
哪个医生又给你说啥了的话，
你哪个亲戚又在怀孕的时候，
生孩子的时候遇到什么问题了，
是候这孩都可以利用起来，
就是在沟通上，
老公这块还是要对，
就是一件小事，
没错，
这块我可能比较薄弱一点，
因为之前涉及到这些时候，
我就直接很强烈的跟他说了，
就不可能我要替我和孩子考虑，
是的，
没错，
有的时候得演戏，
那甄嬛在那个寺庙里面啊，
凌云风跟那个皇帝睡了一觉之后，
其实他那时候对皇帝已经是非常厌恶了，
但是他皇帝醒过来的时候，
他掉几滴眼泪，
能再次侍奉在皇帝身边已经非常知足了，
不图别的，
大概就这意思，
女人啊，
我这块我为我自己说的话负责任，
日子能过得好的女人都是好演员，
绝对是一个好演员啊，
好的好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
我直播间有没有感觉就是我刚说这个话。
你琢磨一下，
日子过得好的女的，
她不光是在老公面前演，
在儿女面前谁不演戏啊？
就你们家孩子画那个画，
画的跟一坨屎一样，
你是不是也得演戏哇？
宝贝，
你画的这个太好看了，
画的真棒，
色彩这么艳丽啊，
这么鲜明，
轮廓这么好，
谁不演戏啊？
一天天的不是跟孩子演戏，
就是跟老婆演戏，
跟公公婆婆演戏，
跟老板演戏，
真的，
日子过得好的女的都是好演员。
孩一子吃饭，
以前不吃鱼丸，
今天吃鱼丸了，
哎呦，
你是不是演戏哇？
宝贝，
你好棒哦，
鱼丸都吃完了。
哎呀，
胃口这么好呀，
妈妈真高兴，
你演不演吧？
人生如戏，
谁都得演几场，
你想让孩子他爸带着孩子玩是吧？
你是不得演戏哇，
爸爸带孩子，
哎呦，
孩子跟妈爸好轻哦，
爸爸带孩子带的真好，
还子现在胆子都大了，
还是得爸爸带孩子，
你是不是练习就这意思，
我那天看到一个小朋友，
他面前有一个摄像的拍他的视频，
这小朋友好像是做数学题，
做了36遍还是28遍，
终于做对了，
终于算对了，
然后他的妈妈就拿着他做的这个数学题，
俺给门外的爸爸去看，
快看快看，
我们天子宝宝这次终于做对了，
然后他爸爸在那边，
哇，
这么优秀啊，
这么聪明啊。
啊，
还且能坚持做36遍啊，
这么有恒心啊，
这么有毅力呀，
终于做对了，
两口子在那演，
然后这小朋友就心里可美了，
做数学题做了36遍，
终于做对了。
李亚戏一听刚刚人说这怎么能叫演呢？
这叫真情流露，
你已经是演到登峰造极了，
就是这个意思啊，
这怎么能叫演呢？
这叫真情流露，
这就是奥斯卡演员演员的顶级水平，
就是你这个水平，
就演到自己都相信了，
演到自己都是真情流露了，
就太牛了啊，
注定你能有好日子过啊，
记得点赞关注哦。